hey we're launching a patreon campaign
to make some of the coolest videos
you've ever seen
he deals that would otherwise be
impossible without your support yo guys
because you're helping go way more crazy
yeah we might go way more crazy for most
of our careers on YouTube
we've prided ourselves in doing a lot
with a little but last year both us and
you guys got a taste of what videos can
look like if we can just get a little
bit more projects like gravity gun
Assassin's Creed 4 Blood Dragon these
are all examples of pieces that had
budgets now imagine every video up to
that level of quality free of any
creative restraints with your guys's
help we can do that
how does patreon actually work well you
select the contribution level and then
each time we release a video that
contribution goes towards the budget of
the next video we make you can think of
patreon like a mini Kickstarter unless
you guys support us on a video by video
basis but you get way more from your
contribution than just being able to see
the next video depending on the amount
you contribute we have everything from
high quality blu-ray downloads song
downloads we have livestream Q&A
sessions we have livestream interactive
tutorial sessions we even have the
coolest of all our actual project files
accessible for you to download but you
guys can download the edit the raw
footage our After Effects files and any
stock footage that we've created that's
in the piece that means you guys are
effectively getting stock footage from
every single project that we make you're
pretty much hacking our computer it's
pretty weird actually for those of you
looking to learn more about visual
effects or editing or even just workflow
in general this is going to be a great
opportunity for you guys to learn more
about that most artists charge people
for their work we're a little bit
different and that we put it up for free
for you guys to watch if you really like
it and you want to support us consider
contributing $1 for the videos that we
make it's going to make a big difference
in our product and it's gonna make a big
difference in what you guys see so if
you haven't gotten to the patreon page
yet go there now and check out
everything we have all our rewards
listed in way more detail than we could
fit into this video and also we have all
our video milestones up there as well
those are the cool video ideas that are
hoping to achieve with your help so
please go check out the patreon page
helped us take our videos to the next
level help support us as filmmakers
we're about to destroy YouTube with
amazing videos this year we're not going
to the YouTube will still be there did
you mess it that's how you're gonna
watch them so please go to
patreon.com/scishow order digital and
help us make amazing videos thanks guys